votre nouveau spectacle ça s'appelle
Glory alleluya en tourné dans toute la
France ça fait déjà marrer oui ça se
marque sur la fiche effectivement est-ce
que vous pouvez c'est un quoi c'est ça
ça s'appelle un glory hall c'est quoi un
glory h c'est NON à la place des micro
ça peut être des caquettes je voulais
dire à à Laura qu'elle le sait pas mais
on s'est déjà rencontré c'est vrai non
mais r pas si c'est vrai c'est moi le
troisième micro à gauche là
sur qu'est qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
affiche euh et ben en fait c'est c'est
une métaphore un petit peu provoque pour
en fait il y a une vraie explication
derrière euh c'est que pendant ce ce
spectacle je raconte vraiment en fait
les les coulisses du premier spectacle
je raconte un peu ce que ce que les gens
nonont nont pas vu il s'est passé plein
de choses dans ma vie et en fait la
métaphore du du gloryol c'est que à
l'intérieur d'un glorol ENF on sait pas
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur en fait et
donc c'est de dire bah voilà dans ce
spectacle je vais vous raconter en fait
ce qui s'est passé euh tout ce que vous
ne savez pas et les coulisses